la porte de métal est tordu pour gravir
les escaliers il faut enjamber les
débris et dans l'appartement y vit serré
tout est perdu pourtant olga nettoie les
dégâts les
merlus beewi
la défiance la rage et les larmes ce tir
est une place dans le coeur des
habitants de karkhiv la peur elle joue
cool et ouf en plus d'un mois de guerre
ils ont apprivoisé yadi pilpa nîmois
locaux d'après croûte et candidat aux
routes et caves dans hnb
pour ce député du parlement ukrainien la
dévastation est un deuil à plusieurs
chapitres
je crois que ça nous fait tous mal de
réaliser que nous sommes tous en danger
dans les zones menacées par l'agression
russe dans les zones d'opérations
militaires il ne tire pas dans les airs
mais pour tuer pour nous défaire c'est
douloureux de réaliser que nous étions
des voisins des parents nous avions un
ailier mais aujourd'hui il ya une chaîne
brisée de familles de proches
d'idéologie blink
il n'a pas quitté kharkiv depuis le
début de la guerre mais il voudrait bien
convaincre les plus vulnérables de se
mettre à l'abri
rien les chômeurs sont pas encore
d'accord il ya un shooter
pas capables ou
encore claude rich
bourgade
nous tranchons notre tranche ilvo chien
en
plein coeur de la ville en périphérie
des résidences des commerces ou des
positions militaires il ne semble y
avoir aucune méthode ou logique aux
frappes de la russie sur la ville
le métro de karkhiv est devenu un refuge
pour les habitants qui vivent toujours
ici une vie parallèle s'y est installé
les plus chanceux ont élu domicile dans
les wagons du métro à laruns un peu de
confort et d'intimité dans ce dortoir
souterrain
c'est ici que galina s'est installé avec
un matelas et des couvertures posées à
même le sol et l'ivi depuis deux
semaines avec sa fille son petit-fils
artyom et rim sont sphinx adoré beaucoup
ne viennent que passer la nuit mais
galina elle n'ose plus sortir
je crains que mes nerfs ne tiennent pas
j'ai vu les bombardements c'est
difficile chaque fois pour moi je reste
ici parfois je monte les escaliers je
marche peu mais autrement je reste là
à la surface car qui dès ses habitants
font de leur mieux pour donner l'image
d'une ville qui fonctionne envers et
contre tout même scarifié jusqu'au sang
par les frappes russe la ville reste
propre et fonctionnel et on cherche à
protéger son patrimoine historique qui
n'ont pas encore été touchées les
frappes s'en prennent aussi aux symboles
de la ville l'édifice de
l'administration régionale n'est plus
qu'une carcasse il a été visé par cinq
roquettes au moins 24 personnes y sont
mortes le 1er mars dernier s'il n'avait
pas eu un peu de retard ce matin là le
gouverneur de la région auraient pu
s'ajouter à cette liste puisque robin
dans les quartiers résidentiels du nord
et de l'est de la ville les édifices ont
été désertées par les habitants c'est
ici que se concentrent les frappes des
russes
les maisons les écoles les jardins
d'enfants ils sont devenus des cimetière
pour ceux qui restent encore la nuit
dernière sept personnes sont mortes et
au moins 34 ont été blessées dans le
quartier de pirate et 4 quai quand la
russie frappe les rescapés sont conduits
ici blessures par balles multiples
fractures ouvertes brûlures graves
traumatismes crâniens les chirurgiens
ont dû se faire à une médecine qui ne
connaissait pas l'ida a encore un
morceau de shrapnel loger dans
l'intestin mais elle est trop faible
pour qu'on lui retire tout
outrage
n'est
pas l'image que tu as chaud
on répare les corps déchirés ici jour et
nuit
mais les âmes resteront meurtri le
directeur médical de l'hôpital ne peut
contenir les tremblements de son visage
peu plus que le désir de vengeance quand
il raconte comment ce qui devrait être
un sanctuaire protégé a à son tour été
ciblé par l'armée russe le 25 mars
domino's pizza
paquet de rester jusqu'à sa mort
je pense qu'ils commettent de tels actes
terroristes spécifiquement pour nous
intimider oui parce qu'au xxième siècle
avec la géolocalisation
tout le monde sait où tous trouvent il
est impossible de le rater ils le font
exprès
22h20 le tout premier patient dont il a
sauvé la vie au début de la guerre était
un soldat russe
il faut un temps pour que le regard
s'ajuste à la pénombre ces vieillards
accompagné de quelques-uns de leurs
petits enfants n'ont pas vu la lumière
du jour depuis près d'un mois
une à deux fois par semaine des
bénévoles risque tout pour leur porter
de quoi survivre il ya
un peu des deux pour y mettre fin c'est
tout ce qu'ils demandent ils ont déjà
connu la guerre à l'aube de leur vie ils
voudraient bien finir le peu qui leur en
reste autrement que terry comme des rats
quand je dis jean christophe qui cochent
dégaine ce club de notre bon ben
moubamba temps brésil est hamonistes au
jeu l'état mobilisera cohérence
beetlejuice
pourquoi rester alors c'est une question
qui hante au détour des quartiers
meurtri de kharkiv parce que nous sommes
forts s'entend répondre ici et que c'est
chez nous nulle part ailleurs peu
importe les voisins